I watched Tebow do this and whatever
snack he was eating it seems like he
gets it so rarely that it really is like
his drug he looked like he was in total
Bliss and I was kind of jealous you need
to find something in your life that
you're as passionate about and you love
as much as Stevo loves monster munch
[Music]
first up this is my default snack almost
any time of the day Ritz crackers
because they hold up Laughing Cow Cheese
because I just think this is the best
cheese and I'm not going to apologize
for it and salami my technique
I usually don't have them served on a
skateboard but I get it this can kind of
get messy I like to just get the top of
the wedge off take a cracker get about a
third of it on there you want to sort of
wrap salami in it because if you take
one bite of this it's just going to be
crumbs right so you kind of got to go
with the whole thing I know it's it's a
lot to think about
oh yeah it's kind of a meal for me and
usually my dog is sitting right here as
soon as I start this process
because she knows there's probably going
to be some Rogue salami or cheese coming
her way oh
here we go Haribo Cola bottles happy
cola this is my favorite airplane snack
and they generally have these at almost
every airport now and they charge a
fortune for them when I fly with my
daughter the last time we flew she was
in front of me she heard this open and
her hand goes immediately between the
seats like this it's like a pavlovian
response with the sound of the package
but anyway these are
these are so hard to stop eating and
then if you're trying to make them last
just take one just keep in your mouth
and see how small they get they get
super thin and clear and
I don't know that's just a thing I would
do when I was bored when I was a kid I
still do it to this day
Cola bottles now you know what to get me
for Christmas
here we go Jelly Bellies pina colada and
I tasted pina colada Jelly Belly it was
like this is the only jelly blade that
should exist it's the only one I ever
want to eat you can find these scattered
all over my car I love them
foreign
do you like pina coladas
getting caught in the rain
eating them out of bag yes I do honestly
candies like these and other ones that I
enjoy I hide around the house
I hide from my kids I'm an adult I can
do that and I can have my own stash
and that's where you'll find these
I'm not Tony where though
all right bit of honeys
I have such a fondness a bit of Honeys
because it was one of the first candies
my dad introduced me to my dad was older
when he had me
he was a child of the Depression and
World War II he already had old school
taste and so this these were already old
school when I was young now I think that
I feel like they're just so vintage
these ones I don't really have to hide
for my kids because they're not feeling
it
would I discovered I've been a honey is
especially on Long skate tours when I
was in charge of the tour and I had to
drive for hours on end or through the
night baby Honeys will keep you awake
because it requires so much energy to
chew them and eat them that suddenly a
15 minutes go by and then eat some more
and then an hour goes by and then you're
at your destination and you didn't kill
anybody because you didn't fall asleep
been a honey save lives
oh wow
[Music]
I honestly didn't even know what the
names of this Taffy was I only know how
it looks and where I used to get it and
we used to get it at Farrell's Ice Cream
there was a ferals in San Diego that was
it that was the place like if you're
having a party everyone's going to
Farrell's and everyone's getting crazy
ice cream when you would walk out of
ferals you walk through the gift shop
and the gift shop was just all old
school candies been a Honeys for sure
but this Taffy was always there the
yellow one was the best everyone is
clamoring for these and see that the
yellow ones are always the lowest Supply
look at that
look at that perfect
oh yeah
that's it I'm 10 again I don't know how
you found these I haven't I haven't
honestly eaten them since the last time
with the ferals
okay Smarties this was my favorite
trick-or-treat treat if someone had
Smarties along your trick-or-treat route
as a kid
straight to their house wait enough time
so they don't recognize you and then
come back to it you can't really
distinguish any of the flavors from one
another and you know there's like a
chalky thing to it which shouldn't work
but it just does I used to keep a stash
of these in a very specific place in our
bedroom I thought that no one knew they
were there and my son Keegan who was
about nine or ten at the time left to
post a note one morning on my cupboard
where I kept these and he just it just
says I took the last Smarties haha
Keegan so I had to find a new place I
forgot how good news are
I don't recommend getting these on a
necklace though it gets sticky it gets
weird and you're wearing your food but
these are the best
[Music]
well thanks for hanging out with me I
hope you learned something or that you
are inspired to try something new I'd
stand by all these choices but for me on
Hawk versus wolf podcast with Jason
Ellis all right well that was delicious
I'm gonna go skate
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]